Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the book of purification in the
chapters regarding
in the subchapter regarding the
reasons or the instances in which is
permissible.
[Silence]
So he begins an narration here on the
authority of
and
is telling us the instance in which or
the story in which the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam sent
along with a group of soldiers to awa
referred to as that
is awa
could literally be translated as the the
battle of the chains. There's a number
of reasons why the scholars mention that
it was referred to as the battle of the
chains.
One
opinion of historians is that it was
called the battle of the chains because
of a chains a chain of mountains that
were on the path and close to the area
where the battle took place. So it was
referred to as the battle of the chains
meaning the chains of these particular
mountains. Another reason is this is the
first time that the companions
saw a phenomenon that would later become
a
rather
a rather
frequent occurrence. And that is that
our prophet sallallah.aii Wasallam. One
of his miracles that Allah gave him and
he did not give to any other prophet
before him was as he said
I was I am given victory that arrives
before my actual army and my actual
presence arrives for a month's travel in
any direction from where I am. And so he
he is given victory by way of terror.
noi
right I have been given victory by
way of extreme panic and fear that is
placed into my enemies one month's
travel from wherever I am. And so
because of this fear when he sent
and the soldiers to
the enemy combat combatants were so
disturbed by the companions arrival at
their doorstep and were so disturbed by
this terror that had seized them that
they actually chained themselves to the
ground on the battlefield so that they
would not be able to run away when the
battle started. And so the battle was
referred to as the
and this happened on numerous occasions
afterwards
when people would hear of the
arrival of the iron battalion as they
were later known as the companions of
[Arabic recitation]
he is the he was sent as the
commander over this army and he mentions
that during this journey we don't know
whether it was when he was on his way
there on his way back most likely on his
way back as some versions of this
narration articulate
he fell asleep or during his sleep. He
had a wet dream and it was very bitter
cold during this time. And so he made
and of course the commander always leads
salah in an army. Always the commander
is the im. And so he made and then led
salah led the rest of the companions
with him in salah as per usual.
forch.
[Silence]
So said, "When I had this wet dream,
it was extremely bitter cold out that
morning. And so when I woke up for
I was afraid that if I did bathe
especially at such short notice that I
might actually hurt myself ser
seriously or even die from this cold.
And so I made and then I led my troops
in.
And so when we returned back to the
messenger of Allah sallallah.aii
wasallam in Medina,
they mentioned this to him. They me you
know whenever soldiers would return or
any caravan that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam sent out, he would
await for them when he was told they
were arriving. How would he know that
they're arriving? Well, , usually
caravans are traveling in the following
way. They have people that travel be in
front of them by a day or two, right?
And this is these horsemen are referred
to as alid
which lit literally translates to the
postal.
the postal, right? Later and also in the
Romans times, they used these postmen
that would wait out at certain posts
along a track and horsemen would travel
very fast in order to deliver messages
at the fastest speed possible. A caravan
would usually have scouts and postmen
ahead, right? And they would have a few
behind too, a day or two behind the
actual caravan in case the caravan
leaves anything, in case the caravan
leaves leaves a person. I mean, Aayisha
herself was left behind once by mistake.
And so they come behind and they
collect, right? And they also protect.
If an army or a a band bandits are
coming for the caravan or something,
these scouts will pick up on it and
and give word. And so when the postmen
would come and inform him that they
should arrive tomorrow, he would wait
for them in the masid, right? And when
they arrived they would make their salah
and then they would come and tell the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam about
all the things that happened you know
the details whatever happened the
outcome of things etc. And so amongst
the things that they told him were was
this occurrence with
you know he he he he made and he led us
in salah in jeneva right
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam asked him he said yeah did you
leave your companions whilst you were
junup in a state of janaba
I want to take a minute here to mention
something.
Notice the wording of this rhetorical
question. He said, "You led your
companions whilst you were jun
but he made correct. So did the
remove the janaba?"
It did. If it did
then he after he finds water he does not
have to make to right
does he let's think about this this is
an important point
okay
person is in jeneva they don't have
access to water or whatever they can't
use it so they make
we have one of two options here either
either
removed the janaba
orum
lifted the ruling of jeneva
but they still have to bathe. So what
this means is that if it completely
removed the the janaba
this means that
even later when the person finally has
access to water they don't have to bathe
cuz they already made
takes its place right
or
it temporarily lifts the ruling of
jeneva
but when they find water They have to
bathe still. Which one is it?
[Arabic recitation]
What about the statement?
So good.
What about making extra salah after he
found water? Does he have to make woo
again?
Do you understand the question?
They didn't he didn't break his woo from
his he reaches town now he has access to
water. He doesn't have to make his but
does he have to make woo to make salah
again?
Okay,
then all of you agree that he's still in
a state of janaba. He is. And that's why
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam here
says,
"You prayed and led your companions in
salah whilst you were in janaba." Yeah,
but he made. Yes, but he's still in
janaba. only
momentarily lifted the prohibition the
ruling the implications of janaba from
him. This is why the scholars have a
a principle that I think all of you have
heard of. He says they say
that if water makes itself present then
becomes invalid. Correct? This is agreed
upon.
So he's still in janaba but
lifts the implications of that janaba
momentarily when until he's able to
access the water until he's able to use
the water until understood. This is an
important point because later in this
same chapter we're going to build some
rulings on this narration. So memorize
it, right?
He says, "Did you lead your companions
in janaba?" And so I responded,
"Oh messenger of Allah, I remember the
statement of Allah." And he refers to
verse number 29 in
which Allah says, "And do not kill or
harm yourselves.
Indeed, Allah is ever merciful to you."
So Allah prohibits that we kill or harm
ourselves, right?
And so I made and prayed. He says, "And
so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
smiled and did not say anything."
What type of sunnah is this called?
Sunnah is three types, right? There is a
sunnah which is a command or words.
There is a sunnah which is actions. And
then there is a sunnah which is
affirmation, affirmative sunnah. So
words meaning any hadith where he says
things. Then actions, anything that he
says or does. This is a sunnah. And then
we have something that he doesn't say or
he doesn't personally do but it happens
around him or in front of him and he
doesn't
prohibit it. He doesn't speak to the
contrary. In this case he smiled which
is a type of action. It's even stronger
in its affirmation which means that was
correct in this assessment. Right? But
he wanted to make sure. Why ask him if
he was correct? Well, he's asking him to
to see if he had an evidence for what he
did or if it was, you know, something
that he just made it or maybe he heard
it from someone else to know why he did
this, right? But him smiling is a type
of what? Affirmation.
It's as if he said it's as if the
prophet said that smile is as if he said
implications wise it's as if he said
you're correct. It's as if he said if
you have a situation did here do as
he did. It's the same ruling. It carries
the same implications. All right. So
we will end with that.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]